hello everyone this next game I'm about
to show you was played in 1959 in a
super tournament that was played in bled
Belgrade and Zagreb it was a very long
event and they call it a super
tournament because well it was the
candidate and it featured eight players
Fischer tall with red shows on Banco
Karras and Smith slot and the winner of
this event would face off against the
Knicks elbow spinnaker the reigning
champion so prior to this game but we
already lost the three games to Macau
and this is the fourth game they played
and it shows that even with the Fisher's
amazing play and well extreme theory
knowledge he was still too young to play
against the magician from Riga so let's
see the game is held Alice white and
Bobby is black d4 Knight f6 c4g 693
Bishop to g7 efore to d6 at the Kings
Indian defense Bishop three two castles
Knight to f3 e5 d5 grabbing some space
Knight B to d7 Bishop to g5 h6 and
Bishop to h4 and this is all standard
theory so the dis move everything is by
the book and here Fischer plays a6 and
he goes out of theory and let's see how
I'll be also it deals with it
natal castles 28 Knight d2 night to h7
Fischer wants to put that f5 be for
grabbing some space on the Queen side
first he wants to exchange this bishop
so then I can go back into the game
Bishop captures Knight captures 9 3 3 27
Queen to d2 King ghostly 723 Knights DG
8 and now Fischer is preparing f5 so
let's see how tall makes it work
Tuggle c5 and now after Fischer's f5
this is what I'll had in mind he
captures Fischer recaptures and out all
those f4 so Fischer captures and doesn't
mind trading between the style place the
Queen takes on f4 and after Fischer
takes on c5 towel doesn't care about the
c5 bone and goes Bishop to d3 Fischer
captures another pawn and is now
threatening to take the knight on c3 and
the knight doesn't really have a good
square to go so tal simply plays rook t1
attacking the Queen and I Queen to f6
getting the out of the way and now
attacking the knight with the pawn and
the Queen
but how already decided a long time ago
the dis notch wasn't important for this
game and he plays rook the e6 attacking
the Queen so forcing her to take the
knight Fischer captures on c3 and now
Bishop takes on x5 and here Fischer took
rook takes on f5 but what happens if you
play something like King to h8 well this
would be over quickly as vertex on h6
check Knight captures Queen checks into
GD 8 and Queen 37 is checkmate so Fisher
is forced to capture the bishop here
captures tall captures on a fight with
check King to h8 and now rope the f3 Tao
does a rook lift and is preparing to get
this rock into the game and notice that
the Queen doesn't really have any
squares to check the White King because
this Knight is doing a great job
protecting and also the queen is
guarding b1 so all is well
Fischer place Queen to be 2m tall goes
rook to b8 and
here Fischer doesn't really have a move
to play if you try something like
quinton g7 for example then root 2 G 3
will be crushing and the only move
Fisher found was the Knight to f6 but
this allows Tao atactic which which
leads to a very good position for him so
we take on f6
with check as an item g8 is pinned
the Queen captures rook captures so King
to g7 on painting the Kings now rook
goes to f8 doubling on the last file on
the last rank and you can see how blacks
position is completely paralyzed 937
Knight to a5 stopping counter play on
the King side rook to b8 nice to see
five and after b5 and Knight to e5 this
is all over there is no defense he
doesn't have any moves and for example
after anymore rook F seven is coming and
it's all over
so in this position official resigned so
this is his fourth loss against Michael
Todd and Michael tile went on to win
this tournament and he faced Mikhail
Botvinnik and won the world championship
title and it will be another two years
before Fischer achieves his first
victory against me hotel but we'll leave
that for another video so yeah this is
the game I hope you enjoyed it I'm sure
Fischer didn't and I'll see you soon
[Music]